listen how much did getting married kind
of influence your music to now that
you're a wife now that I'm away I'm
sorry BAE first red carpet I forgot my
rings so nothing's wrong
nobody panic at home everything's great
I just simply forgot marriage is great
though he sings background on every song
I write now yeah he's getting them
attracts you know the background checks
and he actually writes songs with me -
he's learning he's like this is my
dreams because he loves music so he's
like well I know you les told us that
you are excited to start a family with
Jarrell soon I mean what's it gonna take
not pregnant we're in Spanx but we're
not practice what does it take when a
man in a whoop for anybody loves each
other how much were you looking forward
to that next chapter with Darrell oh my
god if I could be pregnant right now I
totally would never get a pop out like
two kids right now I totally would but I
gotta like tour one more time and I'm
exhausted so like my kid pluses like I
just wanna have time so working you a
new music baby
like when I got married I was like let's
do it like I got inspired and I had to
reel it in listen so we got a dog well
listen we're so excited for the new
album what can you tease for fans what
do you want them to know about this next
era of Meghan Trainor oh man I'm and
seconds of my roots about writing
inspirational a big anthems about loving
yourself and treat myself as the album
and I got a big song couple big songs on
there that are really sassy I'm amazing
teacher so I can't talk about yet but
you will drop on the floor like you are
gonna freak out you got blink once it's
Beyonce here not only celebrating with
glad but being here the same night that
honoring Beyonce and jay-z I was so
honored just to be asked to come here
but I'm also presenting I'm presenting
best reality TV show but sound home so
about and yeah just to be in the
presence of queen bee or if your
multiple PC I met her once and I met JC
once at a basketball game and he shook
my hand and it was like the softest most
buttery lotion Hanna never fell and I
was like I'm never gonna wash this so
what do you smell like power money
[Music]